at the heart of the capitals theater
land the show has gone on at this pub
for over 800 years they've seen off the
plague and spanish flu
but 15 months of coronavirus has tested
london's oldest licence premises to its
limits
monday's socially distanced reopening
will be welcome but only as a first
step a lot of bars they they lost the
heart
the soul when you coming to the bar and
you have to order everything on the
table
is missing something how important is
that moment on the 21st of june a lot of
a lot of is our life some scientists
acquiring whether monday's unlocking
measures in england
are still wise when you look at the
criteria the tests
that the government set for easing the
roadmap the fourth of those criteria is
that there are no
new variants which fundamentally change
the risks
now day by day we're discovering more
about this new variant
but everything we're hearing gives cause
for concern
i put that to the prime minister these
are your four tests for moving to the
next stage of the unlocking
the fourth very explicitly says that
there can't be variants of concern
changing the assessment given that cases
of the indian variant
have almost tripled over a week how are
you passing or
saying that you've passed that test how
are you giving a green light on that
we are concerned about this variant uh
and that's that's the purpose and we're
serving notice
that it we do think i think that it it
certainly
may cause disruption uh to our attempts
to
continue down the road map but it they
don't
at the moment change the assessment
about uh
about step three i'm actually going to
pick up on the um the four tests
additionally
and if you think about the tests and
compare them to where we were this time
last week
virtually everything is the same
situation there is one very important
difference the thing which has changed
is the uh very clear view now i think if
everyone has looked at it
that this truck this is more
transmissible than the b117
and we expect over time this variant
will overtake
and come to dominate in the uk and
tonight minutes published by
sage the government's scientific
advisory group suggesting
that they think it's a realistic
possibility it could be 50
more transmissible than the strain in
kent which was itself 40
more than the original virus nhs leaders
warned today boris johnson has to be
prepared to reverse
unlocking what our members
are really cautious about and they want
the government to be cautious about is
is making sure that the progress we have
made um
isn't reversed we need to be prepared as
a country
um to have the prime minister to say to
us look we do just need to go a little
bit slower we need to wait a week or we
just need to reverse things for a week
or two
but the pm wants people to be making up
their own minds rather than living under
restrictions
i want us to trust people to be
responsible and
to do the right thing that's the way to
live with this virus
it's very clear now we're going to have
to live with this new variant
of the vari of the virus as well for
some time
the prime minister told the nation once
again he has to level with them over
kovid
it's a phrase places like this have come
to dread
samcote sky news